i don't think i've ever
had a block like that it's pretty good
defense
[Music]
this is evan mobley with the cleveland
cavaliers i'm going to show you the ins
and out of how i play defense this is
the breakdown
yeah we're in our zone actually
on this play and so trey's at the top
i guess he sees me so he wanted to go
one-on-one
my job was just to really contain him
and then you see he's driving to the
paint so i just try to use my length and
contest without fouling as you see i
have a high hand early so he doesn't
think to shoot the ball and then as he
starts dribbling i try to keep a
good enough distance to where i can
like if he steps back like he did a
little bit i could come up and still uh
contest a shot and then if he drives i
can also
be there and stay in front and and get
the block at the end i know that uh j.a
and lowry are behind me two seven
footers so
if he's going to the basket i know
me
lowry or jay he's going to have a pretty
good contest on it he ended up putting
the ball on my side and i got the block
how we play our defense allows me to be
in a lot of different spots in different
areas of the floor and
almost always be there for the contest
it's crazy that i defend 17 shots a game
and
already defended 30 shots twice this
year i don't really know
these metrics and
to hear these metrics from you guys is
just crazy the key to holding my
match-ups to under 46
within 10 feet is
really just staying vertical and
holding holding your spot in the paint
and contesting at the top
and always contest without fouling
never leave your feet first and jump
second this is crazy that
as a rookie i'm i'm out here
doing that right now this game was a
tough game close game all the way down
to the wire tatum got the ball
and he started pushing it i was like i
knew he was going to go like the whole
way probably and try to get the layup so
i was just really tracking behind him
the whole time
and then my teammates did a good job of
slowing him down a little bit and then i
just went and jumped for the blocking
and got it i thought he was gonna shoot
it off the backboard i was going to
go for the pin but he ended up shooting
it in the middle of the hoop and
i got there quick enough to not get
goaltending i don't think i've ever
had a block like that
like where it was right over the rim
it's pretty good defense
me coming up with this big block uh
definitely shifted a lot of the momentum
to ours our side and i feel like this
kind of
was like a turning point in the fourth
quarter to like get us to win me being
a
top 25 and
forcing turnovers is
uh
another crazy metric that i didn't
realize i feel like my length and
how well i move my feet really caused
most of the turnovers this metric
uh
definitely shows the value of
my defensive presence because
a lot of times i force turnovers but i
don't necessarily get this deal i feel
like i do that a lot
as well as like altered shots that are
not necessarily blocks but
me just being there changing the shot up
really affect the game in
ways that like a normal statue wouldn't
show you a hero i knew
he was coming off like a good couple of
games i think lowry happened to be
guarding him and then the big set of
screens so i switched and then
i knew he was going to come at me so i
just stayed down and tried to stay ready
basically crab walking keeping one foot
down ready to move either way
and
after he stepped back i i seen him
pulling up so
just
jumped his eyes and as hard as i can and
got the tip usually
uh i stick my arm out and basically uh
use that as like a measuring stick to
really judge how far i am and
if i'm if i can almost touch them i feel
like if they pull up right now i could
probably get a good contest
and then also if they wanted to drive
i can
react in time with the space i have
to stay in front of my man and like
contain them thanks for watching film me
on the breakdown shout out bleacher
report and nba court optics